on a beaucoup entendu parler de
blackrock surtout ces derniers mois la
société de gestion d'actifs créée en
1988 par larry fink est devenu numéro un
mondial du secteur au fil des décennies
l'entreprise est longtemps restée
discrète bien connu du monde de la
finance certes mais pas du grand public
ce n'est qu'après la crise financière de
2008 que les médias se sont mises à la
mettre en lumière en raison de sa
puissance de la taille et de la portée
de ses actifs ainsi que de ses activités
financières
elle gère aujourd'hui environ 6500
milliards de dollars soit 5 1750
milliards d'euros mon pied par ses
clients 6500 milliards de dollars c'est
le pib de la france et de l'allemagne
réunies
blackrock c'est quasiment un état
l'entreprise est tellement puissante à
des participations dans un si grand
nombre d'entreprises dans le monde que
si supposons un venait à faire faillite
cela entraînerait de véritable risque
systémique pour l'économie mondiale tout
entière
par ailleurs et entre autres c'est un
des plus grands investisseurs dans la
fabrication d'armes
n'en déplaise aux pacifistes et l'un des
trois principaux investisseurs dans les
huit plus importantes sociétés
pétrolières au monde
n'en déplaise aux écolos le travail de
blackrock est de collecter de l'argent
auprès de fonds de pension banques ou
assureurs pour l'investir sur les
marchés financiers
son pdg larry fink côtoie régulièrement
des chefs d'état du monde entier qu'ils
écoutent ses conseils économiques d'une
oreille attentive comme le président
mexicain andres manuel lopez obrador
donc etats unis inde allemagne
les conseils de la racing sont partout
au plus haut sommet de l'état et il peut
dire qui sait recruter un article du
monde explique jusqu'en février 2020 la
filiale allemande de blackrock était
présidée par friedrich merckx en lice
pour succéder à angela merkel à la tête
du cd ou en 2017 le think tank de
blackrock a recruté l'ancien chancelier
de l'échiquier george osborne approche
de boris johnson et en octobre 2017
quelques mois après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron une vingtaine de grands
investisseurs mondiaux triés sur le
volet par blackrock comme le rappelle le
monde est invité par l'elysée et
matignon pour découvrir la politique
économique du nouveau quinquennat
en plein projet de réforme des retraites
et le président de blackrock jean
françois cirelli qui reçoit la légion
d'honneur
pas étonnant qu'en france blackrock ne
soit pas vue d'un très bon oeil par ceux
qui depuis de nombreux mois
descendre dans la rue pour protester
contre cette réforme mais pour le
président de blackrock france penser que
l'entreprise aurait un rôle à jouer d
intérêt à tirer de la réforme relèverait
du fantasme absolu
fin de citation pourtant entre 2002 et
2004 jean-françois cirelli a quand même
travaillé avec jean pierre raffarin
pendant la mise en place de la réforme
fillon sur les retraites et nous
blackrock qui avons que vous nous l'avez
dit une expérience nous voulons mettre
notre expérience au service de cette
nouvelle épargne retraite
bah je croyais que c'était un fantasme
absolu bref voilà une entreprise qui
pèse très lourd et dans de très nombreux
secteurs banques industries pétrolières
industries d'armement alors blackrock
nommé conseiller environnemental pour
les banques par lieu un peu comme si on
demandait aux époux balkany et d'écrire
un rapport sur comment lutter contre la
fraude fiscale
bien vu comment se fait-il que ce géant
tentaculaire et été choisi en avril
dernier parmi huit concurrents pour
conseiller l'union européenne sur la
façon d'intégrer au mieux les facteurs
environnementaux et sociaux dont la
supervision bancaire
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi la
commission européenne n'a pas pensé
qu'il y aurait un conflit d'intérêts
énorme avec ce choix
pas impossible en effet mais bon la
commission européenne l'a sur cette
offre était plein et stricte conformité
avec les règles applicables de lieux en
matière de marchés publics et compris
celles concernant les régies bilité des
soumissionnaires et la prévention de
tout et blackrock de calmer le jeu sa
branche conseil qui assurent la
prestation n'aurait rien à voir avec sa
branche d'investissement blackrock se
dit honorée d'éclairer le plan d'action
de la commission européenne sur la
finance durable
bon bah tout va bien alors